[Musica]
aiuta poi drive ma non solo appello a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono pa vj ed assistiamo in un
nuovo blog alla ragazzi vorrei iniziare
questo blog soffermandomi tantissimo sul
primo punto dei blog che di solito lo
faccio ma la faccia abbastanza in fretta
ma questa volta voglio veramente
soffermarmi sulla fan arte della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da tender che ott amber non si
pronuncia tempi tamburo e ragazzi la
cosa in particolare che questa panart la
giudico la fan art più bella che mi
abbiano mai fatto ed è questa ed è
assurda cazzo sempre sembra vi giuro
sembra una foto io all'inizio pensavo
avesse utilizzato un programma di quelli
per c'è per convertire le foto in
disegni ma non è così sono sicuro
complimenti quindi tender per il posto
della parrocchia della settimana te lo
sei meritato conca ragazzi passando alle
news del canale volevo dirvi un paio di
cose abbastanza importanti allora la
prima allora oggi è venerdì che voi
state vedendo perché fatti faccio così
che bruttissimo come gesto quindi
ragazzi o anziché venerdì praticamente
voi state vedendo il log io da maledetto
sto registrando i video del weekend per
chi ha dato che sono lucca comics non
posso registrare video perché sono via
ma nonostante questo sia sabato che
domenica ci saranno tranquillamente
video compreso happy quindi state
tranquilli una news importante ragazzi
che ho scoperto giusto oggi è che sta
per uscire non so quando di preciso ma
usciranno a breve il dlc di outlast ciò
vuol dire che ci sarà un'altra storia di
outlast che stanno sviluppando gli
sviluppatori del gioco quindi tra non
molto vi troverete di nuovo in quel di
hameedi manicomio ragazzi non avete idea
di come ero felice quando ho saputo la
notizia ma comunque ragazzi la verità è
che ho fatto uscire questo blog
abbastanza il blog precedente l'ho fatto
uscire martedì che in genere esce sabato
questo blog l'ho fatto uscire venerdì
che in genere è scesa ha fatto questo
perché ragazzi non ci crederete mai ma
proprio mai non ci potreste mai credere
ma non c'è più spazio in camera per
tenere i pacchi visto che mi devo
liberare di un casinò di pacchi ho
deciso di aprirne altri tre che sono
sono questi sono enormi
non mi stanno marisa aspettatevi faccio
l'equilibrista ok ok ci sono ci sono
perfetto ragazzi devo aprire
assolutamente tre pacchi perché qui non
non vado più avanti quindi ragazzi vero
leader scatolare prima questi perché
sennò tra un po devo assumere un vigile
a tempo pieno in camera mia perché non
si può più circolare cazzo che cosa
bella di stop acque che se e premete in
una scatola delle converse sarebbero un
paio di scarpe in teoria non so se se se
effettivamente mi avete inviato le
scarpe nel caso grazie mille e vero non
sia un altro polo di cona perché
altrimenti vi ammazzo tutti e due
mi avvio ragazzi no no io non ci posso
credere non si possa rivedere la nutella
con il mio no questa fantastica ragazzo
veramente presa presta si chiama nutella
casa anzi si chiama lorenzo dir la
verità piacere mi chiamo lorenzo nonché
ragazzi la nutella e fantastica direi di
passare al prossimo pacco ovviamente ce
ne sono altri due
questo è un po più piccolino e questo è
fottutamente enorme quindi direi di
aprirlo dopo spero che i regali ti
piacciono by matrice regali cioè
significa che ce n'è più di uno
ragazzini nei pacchi enormi ce n'è
sempre uno in quelli piccoli ce ne sono
50 nome la spiegherò maestra cosa ma
comunque va bene c'è qua dentinho
ragazzi cè un miliardo di cose qua
dentro c'è allora da fan art tra l'altro
fantastica di me con in bocca che mario
non questa epica grazie ville un poster
che credo sia un poster non so che cosa
aspettate il secondo ci sono c'è un
poster dei cava grazie grazie mille
amico mio e la la cosa che desideravo
sin da bambino un miniposter con i
cavalli cioè finalmente la mia vita è
potuta mente completa ma non c'è
qualcosa qua dietro
oggi mi iscrivo al tuo canale grazie
mille viva fa vj grazie a questa parte
mi piace molto di più comunque apprezzo
anche i cavalli una bandiera del circo
[Musica]
grazie mille per la bandiera amico mio
sempre desiderato andare a circa poi c'è
una la testa di una tigre e ragazzi
abbiamo un coccodrillo ma aspettate un
iguana e poi c'è questo braccialetto con
con un cuore bellissimo che penso sia
una dichiarazione esplicita e ti amo
anch'io inviarmi un iguana è stata la
cosa più romantiche che qualcuno abbia
mai fatto per me grazie mille
e direi che un testo di passare
all'ultimo banco ragazzi che è il più
grande che ingombrava parecchio la
stanza ed è per questo che ho dovuto
qual è il blog praticamente speriamo ci
sia una tigre sto [ __ ] pacco
maledizione ce la posso fare è una donna
mezz'ora per aprire un [ __ ] pa
coalizione ci sono cos'è sta roba è una
mi avete inviato un xbox 360 e ci siamo
scambiamo trovato casa che cazzo si fa
tazzer in una in una scatola dell xbox
360 non lo so appartate etico
io ci credo ma mi avete inviato un dvd
di antonio casanova perché mi avete
inviato un dvd di antonio casanova
ragazzi che cazzo me ne faccio non
voglio che abbia abbiamo un comodissimo
accesso 4 è un cesso ip dobbiamo
specificare se non va bene con con
comodo stavo faccio il cazzo è sta roba
c'è la tavolozza dice mario fantastiche
ticket set
[Musica]
cuore a pixel
sono troppi coloierà mi piace fare figo
ma non sono tuo amico schemi quella leva
su youtube e guarda soltanto fani genere
perché perché perché no questo non lo
faccio più anche ragazzi detto questo
direi di passare a fa vi risponde la
collanina me la tengo per chi è
fantastica anche su di plastica no vabbè
basta
ciao pennarello quanto e magliette
riesce ad indossare una due tre quattro
che cazzo 5 cazzo se sembro palestrato
qualche a troy aspettate un attimo ad
essi davanti vado in giro con 5
maglietta addosso funziona 678 questo
questo il mio pigiama ragazzi non si sa
come mai avete mai visto un fusto così
indossare un pigiama del genere ai
ragazzi direi basta perché se no devo
ripiegare i 250 miliardi di maglie però
ragazzi nei prossimi blog sta sfida la
voglio rifare la voglia di fare
veramente bene aspettatevi di vederne
300 di maglie ma al selciato channel
perché antiche anni a mezz'aria facendo
un giro di 360 gradi
[Musica]
nicolò signoretta famigie secondo te
quale loro il più spaventoso che hai
fatto un po fatti avrei risposto amnesy
amnesia the dark descent il primo ma
ultimamente ti rispondo outlast outlast
è stato lawlor che ufficialmente mi ha
spaventato di più perché mi ha
spaventato tantissimo e come ho detto
nelle news ragazzi tra poco sta per
uscire un dlc di outlast con una nuova
storia nuovo personaggio principale non
ho saputo di più e andrò a farla
sicuramente perché augias è stato il
gioco horror che mi ha spaventato di più
in assoluto
quindi farò assolutamente il dlc
aspettatevelo la di antonietti fa vi
risponde favi fai una scenetta imitando
il padrino insultando chi è mario
e ciò a gonnesa pil
deve portare le spetta ma lo vedi capita
di di merda che stai facendo nel vero
senso della parola
ti conviene a rispettarlo ma rispettava
la tiriamo lo sciacquone
ma dai ragazzi di levi concludere qui il
blog perché se non l'avesse notato o un
po di roba da mettere a posto perché mi
avete fatto tirare fuori 250 miliardi di
maglietta comunque ragazzi se video è
piaciuto il come al solito lasciato il
momento vi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che un livido trovata nella
descrizione server e cristicchi
iscrivete 15 li vediamo dove cazzo è il
telecomando sente perché gli scritti
iscrivetevi che ci rivediamo in un
prossimo vito bene ragazzi
ma che cazzo
[Musica]